so my name is Jimmy Bogaerts you can
find me on twitter @ @j Bogaerts this
presentation and just [ __ ] everything
I do is on my github and github.com /j
bogart and i blog a lot about this topic
on my blog at Jimmy Bogart calm a few
things about me I'm a Microsoft MVP I
don't really know why I get the award I
fill out some spreadsheet every year and
they keep giving me free stuff and I
accept it so that's good stuff I guess I
work for a consulting company here in
town called head spring and a lot of
what I'll be talking about are from
projects that I worked on at that
company I do a lot of open source stuff
as well you may have heard of some of
those projects over there on the right
you may love them but you probably hate
them wanted to - there doesn't seem to
be any middle ground there um so I want
to talk about today some of the projects
that I've worked on and especially some
of the ones that I've had a chance to
consult on and my work as consultants
for companies that's asked to come in
and look at their code usually people
don't come in to ask to look at they
might look at their code when their code
is good usually it's on the the kind of
opposite end of the spectrum there where
it's something that they don't they're
not really proud of they they they're
wondering why they're having a hard time
changing it's why they're not meeting
their estimates not meeting their
deadlines and in general is when I find
these these code bases and you know
there are a big ball of mud or a
chocolate ice cream stack I guess
something like that so in a particular
kind of highlighted the problem of what
this architecture we'll be talking about
today it tends to solve and so this
architecture was built around an
application that was just a very simple
workflow application so this is an
application meant to approve some some
work items and then there were two
different views of it there's like a
regular user and an admin user now the
virginal developers hadn't built many
new systems in their career they mainly
been maintaining existing systems so as
part of what they were doing for
building this application was you know
how to research about what current best
practices were or building systems and
architectures and so
in this application there were exactly
four screens for this whole system with
the very basic workflow and very simple
role-based security but to get to those
four screens they somehow generated
twenty thousand lines of code and in
this twenty thousand lines of code there
had two separate solutions and twelve
individual projects to be able to build
out these overall force grades and all
these things they were building from
where like supposed to be a kind of
industry standard best practices about
how to build enterprise applications so
when a presented with new out
applications new systems try to figure
out how the pieces fit together
especially something with you know
multiple solutions multiple applications
different projects what I'd like to do
is take a request in the application
that is someone is using something
screen which one clicks a button
so let's trace that request all the way
from the front end to the back end and
then back again and just see what all
the things that need to be touched and
are to kind of follow the business logic
as well as if I need to make a change to
this system what are all the places I
needed touched in order to make that
change so this application starts out
with an aspx page by the way this is
like 2015 did this application was
created so that's like red flag number
one what was we probably shouldn't be
using web forms like ever ever again so
they kind of set the tone for me about
what was going to fight next that of
course ap aspx has a code behind still
no business logic there but this
application uses WCF like you do so the
next thing we talked to is course is a
service proxy now this is not a service
product that comes from WCF this is a
custom one just in case they had to have
additional kind of business logic to do
things so their custom service proxy
this finally talks to the actual WCF
service proxy and this is where the
first solution ends now I open up the
second solution for the back-end part of
the application because we don't want
the front end talking directly to a
database we have to go through some kind
of layer so we have to have this this
WCF service layer tool to be able to
talk to so of course the next thing you
need to do is look for the WCF service
the thing that actually receives the
request from that front end now there
was no business logic there so kept
digging the next thing I looked for was
what the DCF service called in do they
called
a separate project which was the Bao
I'll usually do this talk I asked the
audience like well what do you think bas
stands for because I haven't seen this
this acronym in a very long time usually
it's the B is probably a business and
then L is probably layer a da I had a
digging search for but it was a business
application layer I'm not usually a
business logic layer in case there was
nothing in there it was literally just
delegating to yet another thing so I dug
the next step down to see what the
business application layer talked to and
that was the data access layer the data
set access layer was layer on top of the
data but still there was no actual
business logic being done through all
these different application layers all
the way for the front-end and out of the
data access layer I didn't actually find
any business logic the thing that was
actually doing the world work now where
was the real work actually being done
short procedure so all of this ceremony
all these different layers were just
built in order to call a single store
procedure that actually had the real
business logic but none of the other
pieces was providing any actual value or
any additional any additional I really
value to the either the developer or to
the actual business itself it was just a
bunch of additional ceremony I could
point something like this and say well
obviously this is a bad idea especially
with that application this is small what
happens if you have an application that
isn't just for screens what happens when
we have an application that has many
many screens and we start to need some
kind of organization and structure in
order to handle the different logic that
we're going to run into so you have
something like this it doesn't make
sense to have any sort of structure but
what happens when we try to scale any
kind of architecture like this up to up
to larger systems larger applications
now my me myself I did not go to school
for computer science I was an
engineering degree and so when I first
got out of school and had my first real
application to work with I needed to
learn on how to build systems and build
applications and so when I was taught
and what I found back then was it the
way he built applications is with an
interior architecture oh they I'd never
really saw I guess a little done the
last screen shows like what eight tiers
I guess but most time you see like a
three or four tier and of
architecture where I have a user
interface layer that supposed to handle
the UI logic and in the business logic
layer which for us the business logic
finally you don't want to talk directly
to the database from your business logic
layer so you need to have something in
between and then finally at the database
itself not built of shipped applications
with this exact structure where I had
like you know three projects and plus
the database to be able to handle the
stuff of my system it seemed to work
okay leaves for the projects I was
working in which were usually pretty
small now as it's already good at bigger
applications we found that this kind
architecture didn't necessarily scale so
we went to the much improved version of
this which is the domain driven design
style domain driven design style into
architecture I had to go back and forth
because they look almost exactly exactly
the same
well we used to call it business logic
now it's services and now we have a
domain layer in there as well and then
finally we don't talk directly to the
database we have to talk to the
repository but otherwise the way we
structured the code was was very very
similar to what we saw before maybe a
slight wrinkle there and that we had we
had domain objects that matched the
names that our business used but usually
those the main objects didn't ously have
a lot of behavior
we're easily found the behavior was and
those service objects up above as it was
rare that we could have business logic
that could be completely encapsulated
inside of a domain model and so we had
the services we really found the
business logic that had to coordinate
activities between different things
so in this improved style
we had some applicants some applications
that we build with this with a lot of
success but then we went to an
application that was going to be much
larger in scope and larger in scope I
mean like hundreds of screens as opposed
to maybe a two or three dozen you might
say like well don't build a system with
that many screens but this is before any
kind of like micro service or anything
like that so in this case we thought
we're doing okay especially because we
saw this kind of structure work really
well for small systems and applications
that thought well it worked well there
then why not have it another batch
eliezer application so in this structure
we very quickly started to see cracks in
the system in this kind of architect
we found ourselves organizing all the
code by individual layer we usually had
projects around each of these kinds of
structures so in this case we had if I'm
just dealing with something with a with
a person those there's will be a person
table in the database as well we had our
person domain model they made a person
controller we had the person service for
all the all the business logic around
dealing with this person model really
reside it was in the one service and
then finally of course we can't talk
directly to the database we had their
person repository dealing with all the
data access logic from that now with
this kind of structure when I'm
organizing coded by individual layer we
tend to find that each of these kind of
layer object starts to grow in size and
if our application starts to grow in
size we tend to find these kind of layer
based structures really start to get out
of hand I'm so I'm actually got a
picture of a repository in this sort of
structure this is like actual production
code that I wrote
so although the first example I could
say oh that's other developers into the
bags this is on me maybe this is well
like I actually get the the curly brace
the in curly brace is probably somewhere
near your feet down the floor somewhere
about all these different methods that I
put on top of this repository object the
reason why this thing got so big is
because we had started to have more
complex data access logic based on the
complex requirements we were seeing from
the overall user interface so a simple
repository I just get a single model
back but that's not sufficient a lot of
times we need to get other pieces of
information or that individual domain
object and because we're dealing with
relational databases and have to do
different joints to get different pieces
of information well in sequel and that's
a very simple statement I just select
and then do some joint and here we go
but with our ribs you have to do some
more interesting sort of ORM specific
logic we don't have that arm specific
logic leaking into our service layer so
then we had to have all these very
specific methods to get very specific
things to ensure that we didn't actually
access the RM directly now there are
some ways to mitigate this but the
overall problem we found is that when we
build these objects that stretch across
many different quests as my system that
each method is only used really buy that
one request it starts become a
tangled mess the other big issue we
found was just trying to make sense of
the code itself so when we wanted to
make a change in the system I was a tech
lead in this project at the time and I
wanted to give instructions to
developers of okay when you want to add
a new screen or change a field on the
screen here all the things that you need
to change in order to be able to
accomplish that so I actually white
boarded this I said okay you need to go
to do this object to James this thing
this object is a - James just saying
over here over here but here what we
found was that you actually had a jump
around a whole lot in the solution to be
able to get anything done typically I
think our touch points at that point was
in like 12 different touch points to be
able to add a field to the screen
scattered across the solution and
different projects things like that even
looking at the difference requests in
the system I would trace through
different different individual requests
and then see what different objects that
different requests touched
well we found is that when I have these
layer objects that are more specific to
the data as opposed to the behavior and
things like having service layers that
deal with it just everything to deal
with that that entity or the aggregate
we found is that although it could be
very straightforward for this kind of a
first layer but as I started to to cross
the boundary and cross the lines we
found that one individual method could
be used by a lot of different a lot of
different color paths what that meant
for us was if I have to make a change in
some location or one specific request I
have to do a lot of legwork research
am I going to break anything else in the
system and so what I'd really like to do
in the systems that I building is to not
have to do a lot of research about what
am I going to break because that worries
me a lot I mean I'm not generally a
warrior but I do I do I do worry about
breaking other things in the system so
it would be great if that if I'm adding
a new feature set up functions to an
application
I don't want have to worry about at all
breaking any sort of existing
functionality I can only worry about
adding new things to the system and not
worry about breaking other things so in
my next really big application that I
was gonna be tackling I looked at this
picture it said I don't think this is
this is an improvement I'm I'm not
getting complaints from the developers
just a lot of grumbling about mr.
estimates and things like
that I took a step back and said this is
actually adding value to our developers
is actually adding value to the
organization to our team is this
structure actually improving this system
or not and I didn't know or not so I
thought why don't we just chuck it all
out
that is let's just hard code everything
inside of the controller initially and
then wait for like a month
with everything in the controller I knew
you're not supposed to do that but at
the point at that point in time I didn't
trust these different ways of organizing
things so I said let's just put
everything in the controller and then
stick a step back and say okay now that
we've got something going on our system
let's see if there's any patterns that
emerged from just dumping everything in
controller and see if we can see what
patterns we should be actually
refactoring towards now most of the
systems I deal with are web applications
that is there's some kind of either you
know web application that's that's
exposing HTML or these days a lot of
times I'm building api's and in these
web applications we generally see
requests fall into the two different
major categories that is requests that
are going to get information to show on
a screen or return back to another
service or a request to change
information and that comes in the form
of an HTTP gets and an HTTP POST now
about the time that is going through
this transition of like okay let's get
rid of our our service classes and
repositories and just put in anything
the controller and step back and take a
look at what we've got here around the
same time a new concept was emerging
around these overall concepts of
retrieving information and changing
information and if you look at what
these are actually doing from a outside
of HTTP and from kind of a just overall
structural perspective you can see that
I get is really a query from information
I'm asking the system or some
information and then I want to do
something with it and the other side of
the post is a request to perform some
operation I want to approve this invoice
I want to ship this product I want to
just edit some information on the screen
that is a command to the system say I
want you to perform this operation and
so this led to the CQRS
principal secure are standing for the
command query a responsibility
segregation principle and the overall
idea here is to split those service
classes those layered objects split
those split those linear objects into
two because what we find is that for
each of the those late objects only one
path is ever executed for every single
request instead of trying to jam
everything together in these kind of God
objects split those objects outs and two
basic command and query responsibilities
so CQRS is really just about creating
two classes where once there was one two
classes being at the class for changing
information and retrieving information
separating those out into two so if I go
back and look at this repository that I
wrote so I have no one to blame but
myself I can look at this to say well if
I look at the methods on here they're
pretty much split into these two overall
basic responsibilities I have some
methods on here that about queries so
retrieving information and they're also
some methods on here for commands to
modify information and so I started
looking at all these different layer
these layer types and found all these
layer types I had all these different
methods they were bit they were still
all split up into methods that retrieved
information or methods that changed
information I wanna link to my overall
application I found that when I want to
make a change to this system I'm not
dealing with the entire layer all at
once
instead I'm dealing with individual
methods all the way down from the UI
down to the to the service layer to the
repository it even to the database
sometimes these overall operations I'm
trying to perform are not dealing with
things across an entire layer instead
what they're dealing with is a set of
logic across each individual particle
slice so when we move towards this
architecture I had to come up with the
name of it and the best I can come up
with is a vertical slice architecture
the vertical slice architecture is where
we model and organize our application
architecture around axes have changed
that is a look at what needs to change
in a system and I build these these
primitives around what changes at the
same time and build and organize the
code around
those axes have changed so what do these
vertical slices look like well the first
thing we want to do is move all the code
related to an individual request it
could be scattered across all my
different layers in my architecture move
those over into one single place the
idea here is that if I need to make a
change or add code to a system I don't
have to jump around the the code to be
able to do this I put all the code that
needs to change together physically
physically together in the same place
and we'll see what that looks like here
in a little bit maybe you can imagine
that if I need to make changes to the
view to the to the HTML to the business
object instead of scattering that across
the application into different folders I
move all that that sort of logic into
one single place now this does require
some refactoring in our case because
originally these individual boxes were
part of larger classes that were
designated to these kind of layer types
or each individual layering system but
we found again that if I look at each
one of those layer types that have those
public methods do some work whether it's
change information or read information
each one of those methods is only ever
used on one single code path so what it
can do is take those individual methods
use on those one single code paths and
move each of them into their own
individual class or type and each
individual class or type is dealing with
that one request set of logic for that
one set of work that needs to do is now
completely encapsulated inside each fund
of those individual classes now this is
actually a very state of refactoring you
can go back to the Fowler book written
now 20 years ago and this this exact
arrow is they called out to refactoring
that you can do it's extract class from
a method so all I'm doing here is kind
of a standard refactoring of taking this
one class that's too big and taking each
method and extracting it into its own
individual class but the last thing I'm
doing is taking each one of those
classes and placing it together with
other related classes they are dealing
with that individual request
so this approve invoice reject invoice
and flag in place classes are not going
to live in the same folder they actually
gonna live in different folders because
I want to separate those out too based
on the overall requests in my system and
not the kind of they're the same kind of
thing
I don't put all elephants together I
don't put all drafts together I look at
the oval request my system and say okay
this set of stuff all changes together
so let's put them all in the same folder
now we started out with this this kind
of approach where we just took the old
methods over in one giant service class
and starting to put them into individual
service classes what we found is that
when we were giving this kind of
instructions to our developers to say
okay what you used to do was build us
one service class and have methods just
take that old method and put it into a
class all by itself we started to find
that these service classes started to
really diverge and how they looked and
behaved and so we want to put some
structure and say let's get some
uniformity around these these individual
service classes so that the developers
don't have to think a lot about how to
design or name these things they all
decide of a uniform design and really
the work inside of that those those
classes that's the most important thing
in my system so I started to see that
these things were basically a single
class was the single method that
accepted inputs it had some sort of
output so we can abstract that into
something that handles requests take
some inputs and produces some sort of
output and so this was the abstraction
that we used probably a dozen projects
where we would create some kind of
request handler class that takes some
input and produces some outputs and then
all the requests in our system were
built around this this exact primitive
well I got tired of copying this code
from place to place to place and so at
some points I was goaded into making an
open-source project to do exactly this
kind of abstraction and so that was what
led up to the mediator project by the
way I'm again you can kind of send out
like when that project was created
because I'm not I'm not creative with
names and so that was about the time
that signal R was like coming really
popular and so I thought okay this is
just so this is really just say if the
petition of the mediator pattern so
let's call it mediate are I actually
still don't know how to pronounce that
it's mediate our mediator any case it's
easily Google which is that that's the
most important thing so I took these
primitives and said okay let's let's
let's break this down to an open-source
project it defines something they
can handle requests it defines an input
and also finds an output what I wanted
to do was to apply some uniformity to
this though it says you only get one
input and you only get one output
additionally I wanted to have some
coupling between the input and the
output so in this structure the input is
an I request of T so it's a marker
interface but the key thing here is that
the request knows about the response so
I know what's going to come out the
other side well the other thing we want
to do is not share requests and
responses between individual things in
my system because that would lead to
additional coupling and that couldn't
lead to us having problems when we need
to change things in the future want to
have a very explicit coupling between
request response in my system so that
each request has one Handler and one
response I need to make a change in my
system I had a confidence know that if I
make a change the handler the request or
the response it's only dealing with that
one individual code path now because
we're I'm in c-sharp and it's an object
origin language if I was doing this in a
functional language there's any f-sharp
folks on the call by the way you
probably laughing because this is really
just a functional style of building
applications but I've been C sure if I'm
an O and and trying to build a
functional style is just ugly as hell so
I'm not going to try to do that instead
we have to have this object-oriented
style I'm also going to be using
dependency injection for these request
handlers to be able to inject
dependencies so whatever you think
whatever that request handler needs to
do its work is going to be injected in
its constructor as opposed to passed in
through that handle method now with HP
net core this is now super easy to do
you can just say add mediator and give
it to the give it a type or assembly to
scan for handlers and will register all
those Engler's that you can find mi di
container but that's not the most
important part just I need some way to
find all the handlers and so this is a
one line way of doing it
so I have a way to define requests
handlers and responses so how does this
actually track back to the overall
application architecture that I'm trying
to deal with which is CQRS application
having gets and posts how do i model
this in terms of handlers
well if I look at a query a query is is
eventually gonna track to to some method
on a controller likely and that
controller is going to have some logic
what I'm going to do is take that logic
and move it into an overall handler to
be able to handle that query so for the
query side we're gonna have some sort of
query definition and that's going to be
passed to a query healer and finally the
response is what's I give back to the
end user either to an API or to render
as HTML and a post is going to be very
similar I'm gonna have some definition
of the command information that I want
to change and then that's going to be
given to a handler and finally I'm gonna
have some sort of response so this comes
down to having for each of these
handlers one model in and one model out
so in terms of modeling the request of
my sips of system it starts to become
very straightforward just defining these
query objects that finding the response
objects and then my developers are
really tasked with coding that code and
the handler be able to accept the
request and fulfill the response now
these handlers are intended to have
complete encapsulation over their
requests in the response so anything
that that's handle needs to do should be
inside of the handler and that's and not
something that's done before the handler
or after handler I'm the general idea is
that from the application perspective I
get I receive a request I hand it off to
the mediator to head off to a handler
and then I receive a response but inside
of that is a complete black box to the
application and in terms of what the
logic it actually being performed inside
of there we'll see here a little bit
what that entails because that box can
be big or the hailer so we're gonna have
to deal with that in some form or
fashion so let's look first at how we
would model the query side of the
equation now the query side is dealing
with first that request object coming in
so if I looked at an overall controller
action before I performed any that
refactoring
I need to look at this controller action
say well what what constitutes they
quote request in this system
and for a request it's a few things well
first of all it's the request parameters
to this controller action that defines
the inputs to the overall handler it's
those things I'm passing in through the
query string that are going to be passed
eventually down to my overall request
handler now some queries are simple as
they don't have any parameters passed in
through the through the controller
action method and so those query classes
that we request classes are just going
to be empty but they are going to be
scoped so you can see here that this
query class is scoped under an index
class and so I could either do
namespaces or classes however I want to
do it I want to make sure that this
query request is logically defined under
some kind of structure that corresponds
to the requests in my system this is not
any generic query used for anybody this
is the query used for an index page on
some specific section of the application
now some queries are going to have
parameters and so those are going to be
the the action parameters the query
string parameters or if you're using a
web a desktop application it's the form
information on the screen um all of
those different parameters those direct
inputs into the requests are going to be
properties on my request object I just
take all those different action
parameters and create properties my
query that will eventually be passed out
to my my overall handler the general
idea here is that my handler shouldn't
have to reach back out to get input
information for its request it should
all be the request object so it just
takes the requests and can just perform
what it needs to do based on those
direct inputs to intuit now quarries
could get complicated right I could have
paging and sorting and filtering I can
have complex search trains with lots of
fields on them and all those fields all
this almost all the different form
fields are just going to be mapped to
properties on this overall request
object so I have the request object
defined but you notice that the class is
defined as a request of some response
type and so I also have to define what
that response look like now the response
how did a pin
on what kind of application on buildings
I don't build the responses in a vacuum
those responses are really defined and
designed based on how this one request
needs to be performed and used by either
the subsequent parts the application or
the end user but I want to make sure
that everything the next step needs to
do to perform its work is on that
response object at the door doesn't have
to go through additional changes or
enrichments it's everything that's
needed to do to now pass it to the user
interface or the next system is all on
that response so I went back to my
controller action said okay how do we
how can we define the outputs to the
next step in the process whether it's
written or HTML or returning JSON so
click here and say well let's just find
all the outputs I'm passing back to the
end user and this kind of depends what
kind of application architects you're
working with you're working with NBC or
web api or razor pages this is the
although stuff that needs to be passed
to kind of representation step of the
web prop web request process to say I
need to take this data and now transform
it into HTML JSON XML whatever it might
be so this case I look at what are all
the things in my controller action that
are that are data to be passed to the
overall representation rendering step of
the process I've got you back stuff I've
also got a a strongly typed the view
model then also passing as well so all
of those different pieces become
properties on the response object and so
all those different pieces though like
all the different things I'm showing on
the screen are then now pulled up into
the response now one key thing here is
that these responses need to be very
dumb DT o--'s or data transfer objects I
don't want any kind of like ORM entities
and any framework things where if I go
down the wrong property path now it's
making a behind-the-scenes database call
I want these things to be as dumb as
possible and represent only the
information I'm going to show on that
screen some of my systems would just
pass through entities all the way down
to the view or out to the end user but
that could pass much more information
than they actually need I want to make
sure that the response models things
coming out of the handler are only the
information necessary
to be able to pass back to the end-user
and nothing more so simple models would
just be a set of property it's just like
a flat set of properties and nothing
else and so if I looked at this is
probably dealing with some kind of
domain object a domain object has a lot
more stuff going on but I don't want to
give everything back to the end user I
only want to get back the information
that's necessary to show on that screen
but pare down all the properties being
only the things I'm showing the screen
and nothing more now sometimes you can
have more complex responses to queries
so in this case I've got kind of like a
parent-child relationship with a model
I've got some kind of summary
information as well as a table of detail
information as well and so the way I
model that is with just a single class
that has the top-level properties and
then a list of objects that is the table
of properties they're going to be
showing down below on the screen but
what I'm not going to do here is go back
to my old way of pulling back the full
domain model for that's that child
property I'm so gonna create a type that
is only the information we're gonna be
showing in that piece of code on the
screen and nothing more and then sure
they don't accidentally share that that
that DTO amongst other parts of my
application I'll actually nest those
models to ensure that you don't
accidentally pick up the wrong class or
wrong type everything sort of captured
and capsulated in this one single
request okay so now that I've got the
request object I got the response object
now is the middle part like the meat of
the code which is going to be that query
handler now this at this point we just
taken the code that was hard-coded in
the controller action and we just stuck
it in the handler we made me model the
request model response and then the last
little piece was whatever I needed to do
to be able to you take the request and
build off the response so sometimes this
is going to be very very simple um we
still use autumn a poor a lot in our
projects so in this case I'm using auto
map or projections which translates the
DTO into a link select statement which
eventually gets translated by the query
provider and to a select statement that
is just the properties they find on to
DTM so in this case with this automat
projection which is that line that says
project
I'm projecting an entity to a DTL and
that projection through Lake results in
a sequel statement that is only the set
of properties that have selected as part
of that DTO nothing else nothing more so
by going through this kind of projection
step it ensures that I don't have to
have any kind of like lazy loading or
anything like that the the query
provider looks at the Select projection
and then makes the exact sequel
statement necessary to be able to put
that data into that into that DTL now
sometimes my queries get complicated
so my handler can if it wants to then
drop down into whatever kind of data
access strategy it wants to so this case
it's using sequel just kind of raw
sequel to be able to get the information
out this course is a I'm a dumb sequel
statement but I have had cases where the
sequel gets very complicated and my ORM
is no longer sufficient or effective and
being able to to take that sequel and
then fill out a DTL so in some of my
projects we have two different libraries
we use for right paths and read paths
for right paths we may use the ORM and
if a repast we may use a microarray or
something like dapper that is just
responsible for taking sequel and
produce and then fill that into a dto um
but the key thing here is that that
logic that strategy of how to fill the
requests how to take the request and
fill the response is 100% encapsulated
inside of this individual handler so
this handler needs to change it has go
from entity framework to something else
I can do that in this one spot and not
worry about affecting any other handler
in my application and system that's
pretty comforting for me as a developer
say I know that if I change this spot
I'm not affecting any other requests of
my system and if any of the request
changes in a system they're not going to
affect me so inside of my handler I can
do whatever I want to be able to fulfill
the request it could be an RM it could
be one of those micrograms I could call
out to an API I could go out to some
other web service or something that's to
be able to build the response I can
combine these things together however I
want to look a bit whatever I want to in
this handler to be able to fulfill that
request and that's
100% encapsulated for my system from the
from the calling logic I should say now
something needs to know how to like fill
in the details of the ORM HD client so
in these systems you're gonna have some
setup code but that's really no
different than any other kind of
application architecture strategy is you
will have to configure these different
items in some kind of like setup
configuration but that's regardless of
the strategy you'd have to do that
anyway the key thing here is though is
my calling logic doesn't know about that
it just says here's the request do
whatever you need to do and then give me
the response let's go on to the next
step now as we build out these overall
handlers in my system we may run for the
case where we find some sort of
duplication between individual handlers
now I will say that this happens much
less frequently with queries than with
commands with queries it's not that
common that you have to query common
data across a set of requests but it
does pop up from time to time and so
when I see duplicated logic between
multiple handlers what do I do what I do
is actually behind me somewhere if it's
reach for the Fowler refactoring book
because duplicate logic amongst multiple
classes is again I say a well defined
code smell with well-defined refactoring
techniques to handle and and and gather
that common logic together so that those
different classes handlers and be able
to do that now queries themselves I tend
not to extract a lot of complex types
and classes to be able to encapsulate
they common logic um it could be a class
it could be just a static helper method
a lot of times what I do is do stew
extension methods on top of whatever
data access thing I'm using so if I need
to get like what is the current logged
in user or give me the the roles and and
permissions for this user I just go to
an extension method that's encapsulated
all that logic for me and each of those
handlers calls into that common logic so
they have to be very very careful here
is when I have two handlers now using
the same logic well that does introduce
some coupling so just like the fellow
book reprimands just because I copied
the code once doesn't mean that I do
extract that into some common clothes
but if I copy it twice that could be a
indication to me I need to extract that
logic into some kind of common location
it's not required but it is a indication
that I need to do so okay so that's
queries let's now look at commands a
commands even though the the overall
structure looks similar about requests
in the response the commands are going
to look much different than the queries
in terms of the requests and responses
the commands going to have a lot more
going on in the request types because
the commands are going to have to have
all the information the user system has
entered in order to perform and fulfill
that request
so in this request where I'm needed to
edit this information I need to decide
what are the different properties that
are going to be on the request but what
I'll do is just look at the form on the
page and say well I've got these inputs
on the screen those just need to be
mapped to the request object to be
delegated to the handler and if I'm
building the task space user interfaces
that is user interfaces that have user
user experiences that tie back to a
specific task the user is trying to
perform and not a generic tasks like
create thing edit thing but instead very
specific to what that user is trying to
do then each of these these buttons each
of the forms on the screen are going to
be defined around each of these
Foursquare requests handler and
responses so each of these kinds of
tasks or actions that use once reformed
are going to be separate request
handlers types and responses so every
single button on the screen becomes its
own individual request handler in
response so if you're building task
based user interfaces and I find that
this kind of approach actually fits very
well with that kind of user experience
strategy now what about the response we
saw with queries and that queries
usually had a very small request object
very large response object well if I
with commands is that those have been
flipped
and commands the request object is much
larger and the response object is much
smaller we could have some requests that
have no response there's a ask the
system perform the thing but the only
thing I need in confirmation is that it
didn't throw an exception so I passed
the handler does its work as long as it
didn't throw an exception then we can
safely understand that it was successful
a lot of times I will have some kind of
response as part of that where I have a
request I need to have some kind of
feedback from the handler to know not
just was you know did not throw an
exception but some additional feedback
um it could just be as simple as success
fail like true or false that the thing
was successful not that I don't have
exceptions be the thing that tells me it
was successful or not
I want an actual like boolean value that
I can check and the calling logic to be
able to perform some alternate path
based on failures it could be for some
requests that I'm not just returning to
true or false but I'm also returning the
identifier of the thing that you
modified or created so in the case of
the creation path I say ok I want you to
create this new thing the handler is
going to return back the ID of the thing
you created so that the calling logic
whether it's an API or controller and
then issue that redirect to say F you've
created the thing and now redirect you
to the URL of the new thing that you
just created but this can get complex
we've had some cases where it's not
sufficient just to say you know
true/false success but if something
failed I need to have the reason why it
failed so kind of a kind of a domain
validation sort of response and so for
those I might have you know the actual
payload of the response as part of just
one property in that command results but
also have the reason why it failed and
then I just simple boolean to say was
this a successful or not so I can check
and the calling go to say what's the
successful and the doom some other logic
and if it's not successful and I will
show and return the failure reason back
to the end user about you can't approve
this invoice because it's already been
cancelled whatever that logic might be I
don't care about that um and so when I'm
building out these applications my
system we start to notice how
of a natural coupling between some
requests in some response so in a web
application when I first want to show a
form on the screen I often need to make
a request to the system to stay give me
the information for this form I'm going
to show on the screen so in a
server-side rendering application you'd
have an initial gift that is to show the
form and then you click the button and
that's the post to perform the response
and so I can I can model that explicitly
to say the query is a request that
returns the command which is just a
prefilled information and then if I the
command has then the user modified
information that they can then post back
up to perform that action now finally
looks like at the command handlers
themselves now the way I catch my team's
to go through this the CQRS journey is
don't try to performance or premature or
upfront optimization or design of these
overall handlers if we can build up our
refactoring techniques and and chops
then we should be able to take those
handlers and refactor them to what we
want them to be based on the actual
logic we see in them so the first thing
we want to do is just make it as dumb as
possible so just make it the dumbest
most procedural code just hard code
everything just procedural as much as
possible in the fowler enterprise
application architecture book this this
kind of code isn't it as a transaction
script rabbit transaction that's just
procedural code to just perform all the
steps in the in the action and be done
with it so I tell my team just start
with that start with them the most the
dumbest code it could possibly work and
then we can take a step back and say it
what does it actually do I want think
that is different with our systems
probably a lot of other folks as we we
tend not to have any abstractions around
any of the dependencies we can use this
is this all basic that came out of when
I first D factor the application into
everything in the controller hard-coded
we decided that we'd only introduce any
kind of encapsulations or abstractions
on top of our dependencies when we felt
pain so this is same thing I tell my
teams is only introduce any of the only
introduced any kind a pattern or
abstraction or encapsulation when the
code itself or the tests themselves
demonstrate the need through some kind
of pain point so coat smells pain points
those are the things that drive us
towards any kind of patterns we want to
use in our system now command handlers
unlike wear handlers can get very
complicated so we need to make sure we
don't panic this is natural in our
systems and applications what we need to
do is rely on our old friend red green
refactor from our TDD stuff I don't I
don't do a lot of TDD days these days I
do a whole lot of automated testing in
terms of like what happens when it kind
of depends on what I'm doing at the time
but the overall steps are this are the
same and that I want to make sure that I
start with the failing tests I make it
pass and then I take that step back
the step that most people skip and look
at refactoring the actual business logic
behind the scenes so this is the same
thing a guy my Teamsters as you're
building an application make sure you're
taking it step back as you build each
set of thing in the system step back and
look at the code itself
see if it's exhibiting any code smells
and then refactor as necessary so what
kind of things might be fine and these
handlers well the two big kind of
refactoring things the factoring book
things behind our large class and long
method basically go together because we
have a single handler class our single
single request handler class with one
method so if the classes are just
because the single method is very large
and the way we can address those codes
nouns is very well documented in the
refactoring literature there's a set of
refactorings we can apply to this code
to get it cleaner and include things
like extracting a class extracting a
subclass I don't do that one very much
usually it's distracting class track
interface replace method with method
object compose method is the one that I
use a whole lot compose method is taking
a long or large complex method and
breaking going to cook the complexity
down into a similar level of
encapsulation or abstraction that when
you read the method becomes much shorter
and each statement is another method
that's being called it does well
overall step in the process so that
would I use a whole lot which is
basically just a long method I extract
methods for all the different steps
usually my developers have added code
comments and what I do is just replace
those code comments with a method that
actually does the work um often times I
will extract methods outs and I find
then that met that is really dealing
with logic of some other object and so
after I've extracted that method I look
in the medicine it's this method really
dealing with a lot with a lot of stuff
and someone else some other object and
so for factory there's then to move that
method over to the other object to have
that logic word works dealing with the
rest of the information and that system
of course extract method is just another
kind of thing I do with that compose
method as well and this deals with logic
on one individual handler but sometimes
the the logic of my handler becomes a
bit more complicated than just simply
extracting and moving methods isn't
going to deal with the complexity I see
in that Handler and so my second
favorite refactoring book and help deal
with those code smells and this is
actually my favorite patterns book I
know people don't end like design
patterns these days but we use them all
the time maybe you just don't call them
by their name anymore and so this this
patterns book there I love it so much
because instead of being just like a
catalog of like here are the twelve
patterns that we've identified and it's
up to you to figure out when you should
use them instead this book talks about
code smells and using code smells as the
way to drive into refactoring patterns
I'm driving to design patterns and so
some of the patterns that I tuned to see
the code smell take them to see things
like combinatorial explosion I bunch of
ifs our switch statements
I have feature in be like I have one
object using stuff from another objects
are duplicated code between my overall
overall handlers so let's look at
example of this so I've got example here
where I've got a handler that's got way
too much going on in fact you could see
again I don't have the closing brace we
get some closing braces like down here
somewhere on the floor I guess and it's
just doing too much logic and so I can
look at this and say well what is the
work
being done here and most of my most of
my request handlers have like I need to
get the thing either database that have
performed the business logic and then I
saved the thing and they get the thing
and the save the thing those are the
uninteresting parts the interesting part
is all the stuff in the middle so it's
usually that middle part of the handler
that that's the stuff I really want to I
want to I want to refactor it and and be
able to encapsulate it somewhere else so
I look at all this code in structures
down here somewhere that's the stuff
when I want to first typically first
extract a method outs and that tells me
like what information it's using to
perform its work and then I will push
that behavior somewhere else
so that that that logic and behavior can
be tested independently of this overall
set of business logic and if I'm doing
behavioral models and domain driven
design the place I typically push that
behavior down into is into my domain so
now I have the data access code is in my
request handler but the business logic
handling has been delegated down into my
overall domain so now all that logic
that was extracted onto method I now
move that method over to the domain
object now domain object has the the
data coming in performing the business
logic to do its updates and then when
that's done I can now save the changes
for that for that object whatever I did
to it now that's that handle method has
all the information it needs to be able
to perform its work so it may include
the request object but it may include
additional information to perform its
work but it is still encapsulated from
other kind of handle methods and said
that domain object where I am still
dealing with that one individual request
and not other things going on
yep all the logic being pushed down into
there now there are some times where
it's not feasible to push it down to the
domain objects so in that case we often
do have a kind of a domain layer it
includes all of our domain objects and
domain services be able to coordinate
requests between coordinating activities
between different models so in those
domain services I could have roaming
like a more a more complex
invoice approval set illogic so I might
have a invoice approver service that
handles the meat of the business logic
but the general idea is I just used kind
of standard refactoring techniques to
take the the large set of logic inside
my handler and move that over to other
objects to be able to encapsulate and
test independently now some other things
have to worry about kind of
cross-cutting concerns include something
like validation now validation is
something you have to still deal with on
every single request so how do I deal
with validation in this kind of
application architecture well I didn't
to take a step back and say there's not
just kind of a single kind of validation
that to deal with in my system and
there's actually kind of multiple levels
or layers of validation that hatch
perform so that deals with different
validation scopes I have the the initial
validation of the request validation I
can just look at the request itself and
nothing else to be able to say is this
request valid to be submitted you can
kind of think of this as if you looking
on a paper form that what are all the
things you have to fill in to just
submit the form in the first place so
what about the required fields and kind
of just standalone data validation that
just ensures that you know like a
captain said on your keyboard that
you've actually fit you filled out all
the data appropriately on that form just
by itself now once I've performed that
request level validation and I typically
have some requests that have to look at
other things to be able to validate that
request and so that validation it's more
command level validation so you can
imagine like if I have a page that has
to approve an invoice and we have a a
business rule that says you can't
approve canceled invoices well in the
request validation I don't have that
original status on that request that
status is further down in my domain so I
have to go into my domain model or to
the database to say well what is the
current status well the status is
cancelled then I need to invalidate that
request and say you can't do this now
request validation can be very simple I
typically Center request validation on
those requests themselves and pick some
kind of framework to be able to
to do that kind of validation so in this
case I'm using full of validation
because fluent validation has this
generic argument that fits very well
into my request models but a lot of
times I just stick with data annotations
validation
I just decorates my request object with
data annotation saying this is required
this should be a date future this should
be great in that field as long as they
can fit into data annotations then I
know it's it's good for request
validation but as soon as I have to step
outside of that request that's kind of
when you notice data annotations
validation falls down or any kind of
like attribute-based validation so in
that case I start to look at domain
validation so here's an example one this
is a method on my domain model my domain
models not just performing the business
logic but it's also doing the domain
validation or the command validation of
that request in this case the approved
method isn't just performing the work of
approving the invoice instead it's also
looking the the status of that invoice
to say whether or not you can do this
thing or not another result that's
returning is not just true or false or
void it's actually returning a command
result object that says was it
successful or I want to fail this this
command and here's the reason why like
can that approve a rejected order now
this is definitely more complicated than
just like request validation with just
putting attributes on my request so I
only do this kind of structure this kind
of validation would it make sense in
projects I basically wait until the
validation becomes too complicated or
becomes too much for the request handler
to do and they start to move towards
this kind of pattern now the last thing
we want to look at is how do we build
out those responses what do those things
need to look like and if I'm looking at
these these responses these these really
represent representation I'm going to be
showing to the end-user those responses
in to be built based on the
representation I'm going to be showing
at the screen now make controllers if
I'm going a kind of a API based sort of
approach my controllers start to become
very very small and my controllers are
really just there to perform routing and
nothing else if you're using a v-neck or
you can use razor pages which actually
fit
well into this kind of structure and
what all of the different pieces need to
perform that operation can be
encapsulated inside that razor page or
right alongside it so when I go to the
code I'm application I can find the
razor page as well as everything needed
to fulfill that request directly
alongside it broken out into individual
classes for those individual
responsibilities the data that I didn't
show on the screen becomes that model
then I return back to the UI now what
I'm a pee eyes are going to be a little
bit different because often times Web
API show they have different requests
that come in two different handlers but
often times I'm dealing with some kind
of single page application or just like
a react to UI and that's I perform a
request but it doesn't go to a different
screen the extra stays on that one
screen and usually what an update of
that information I show on that screen
so this is one of the cases where I
actually do share a response model
because those response models are really
there to drive the the end user
experience and so that end user
experience is shared therefore the
response needs to share as well now
there are going to be other cases of
which I have cross-cutting concerns
across kind of every single request my
ami system and if I have duplication
that's not specific to one individual
request but really to all overall
requests then there are other patterns
to be able to wrap my overall Handler
with additional behavior to have that
duplication removed from all of my
requests and so this is really just a
decorator I can now direct all of my
handlers with some kind of behavior in
this case I called a pipeline behaviour
because I sold a name from someone else
but these are just decorators and these
decorators can stack so that I have
similar to like action filters I have a
behavior around all of the requests and
responses in my system that it can
perform some action outside of all of my
requests going on
so transactions are good example this
what if I want every single request on
my system to have a transaction around
it when every single command in my
system to have a transaction around it
well this is really easy to do with a
with a decorator and the form of a
pipeline behavior so in this decorator I
perform the transaction I begin the
transaction
I await the next step in the process
which could be handler or it could be
another could be another decorator
behavior and then I commit the
transaction and return the response
something goes wrong they never rollback
the transaction some cases I may have to
implement a unit of work so it's a
similar kind of process where I await
the next thing and then I complete the
unit of work after that next thing has
completed and then return back the
response so I've had to do this in cases
where the ORM you I'm using doesn't
implement the unit of work pattern then
I can do this to make sure that all my
handlers don't have to do this unit of
work handling itself it's just for them
already in this decorator I can do they
like and of things like concurrency and
retries so in this case I'm dealing with
cosmos TV which can return have a
concurrency exception so if I receive a
response back that says there's some
kind of concurrency problem then I can
just transparent lis retry that
operation perform the operation again
and then try to add some end number of
times before I go ahead and fail things
like logging - all this sort of kind of
common cross-cutting concerns are things
you have to worry about I want to have
multiple requests and multiple handlers
in my system registering these I have to
do explicitly because I want to have a
specific order with this so I want to
make sure that I you know I register in
the order that I want them to actually
execute and the last thing I thought on
quickly is testing these systems I feel
like at testing in this overall kind of
flow it actually Maps very well to the
different parts of tests which are
arranged act and assert the arrange is
really setting up the requests and data
needed for the handler act is calling in
to the handler and then assert is then
asserting on that response with this
kind of approach though I do make sure
that I've hurt my reproduce reality as
much as possible so I will kind of I
will execute the same startup stuff that
my application does ensure that when I
call to the handler and matches as much
as possible as what production does
individual requests will also map
exactly to how the overall application
actually performs requests so I look at
the code that that's doing and say let's
go ahead and perform this application
logic as well and when I need a set up
data setting up data in a real system is
performed in transactions so I also make
sure when I set up data and my tests
it's done as part of a transaction as
well when I send request down to my
mediator that's also done as part of a
overall scope requests and transaction
let make sure my test would I want to
execute a healer it's actually
performing overall scope transaction and
in my tests themselves they start to
look very much like kind of an
acceptance test where I'm sending
requests down I'm testing things based
on the results coming back out slice a
new query down and certain the results I
do make sure I try to test through the
front door that is I will send the same
request down to setup data as the user
interface what you do so the same thing
requests calling the same handlers the
UI does to ensure that the test setup
words the data setup is very similar to
my application sometimes it doesn't work
so I'll set up data directly when
necessary but in my my tests themselves
it's complete round-trips throughout
every single step in the process it
match as much as possible how production
actually works but instead of going
through like HTTP or selenium something
like that instead it's working one level
down through my request and handlers so
what does it look like in terms of kind
of the test pyramid we wind up having
our integration tests dealing with the
overall handler and behavior pipeline
but then unit tests are going to be
testing directly that rich domain model
that I've been root factoring towards as
I build out each of these individual
handlers don't unit tests handlers a
unit tests the naturally isolated domain
model so you takeaways here vertical
slices in this approach make it very
easy to add change and delete code we
want to make sure we don't skip that
refactor step we never should be
skipping it but especially with this
approach because things just going to
handler first we want to make sure that
we take that step back look at the code
smiles and perform that refactoring if
we're doing domain driven design those
refactoring is going to be with a
specific direction in mind which is to
push the behavior down into your domain
and then finally want
make sure that we're integration testing
hammers over unit test domain so that
was vertical slice architectures say yes
to celery and say no to the sticky
layered architectures this is on a
github I could have a calm sauce
presentations there's a bit late to an
actual code example wise thank you very
much and hope you'll have a great rest
of conference for me it's time for